so i want to finalize our conversation
about uh donald trump getting impeached
a second time
as we've been filming the house has
started to move forward with what i
described earlier
um an initial proposal for the 25th
amendment to be invoked every indication
that that is not going to happen and
then impeachment will be
subsequently the path forward we also
spoke earlier about how some republican
officials now say
that uh it's time for trump to go even
that he should be impeached we talked
about
pat toomey saying trump should leave we
talked about chris christie saying that
that
trump's inciting of the violent
insurrection is certainly impeachable
but where is the public on this that's
the next question and we do have new
polling on that according to a new
reuters ipsos poll
57 of americans want
donald trump to be immediately removed
from office this is sort of like a
do not pass go did not collect 200 type
of thing and it is of course
directly related to his encouragement of
the protest
last week which escalated into a deadly
riot
inside the u.s capitol building most of
the people who want trump removed are
still democrats
republicans remain much more supportive
of donald trump
and uh seven out of ten of those who
voted for trump in november
oppose his removal um but again when
it's
only 70 of republicans who are against
the removal you end up with a situation
where
led by democrats with many independents
and some republicans the majority of the
country
it's not disapproves of the job trump is
doing
it's believes that donald trump should
be
removed so there's a few different
aspects to this
one yes it's notable that so many people
in the country want the president
removed
but what's the other side of that it's
the same as what we've been saying when
we've looked at donald trump's approval
over the last four years
how is it this low in other words it
should be dramatically more
than slightly more than half of
americans wanting
the president removed the exact number
right now
is uh 57 percent when you blend
democrats independents and republicans
you end up with about 57 percent of
americans
wanting trump to leave office what about
the rest of them
and uh it's disappointingly low and i
think it's important to remember
you know we've talked today about this
idea that impeachment could be divisive
or
whatever the case and how i think those
are really bad arguments
i think there's another aspect to this
that's important to broach or to bring
up once again
impeachment is not about punishment
impeachment is what you do when the
facts
say that it's warranted and if the facts
say that it's warranted
it must be done and one of the reasons
i've seen
some be hesitant to support impeachment
is they don't believe it would be a
sufficient punishment
because trump is leaving anyway i think
that that's both not the point and also
irrelevant because there is a mechanism
through which the senate can vote
if the house impeaches the senate can
vote to convict
but they can also vote to strip trump of
the ability to run in the future and
that requires only a simple majority
and there are more things at stake there
is trump's million dollar a year
uh ex-presidential travel budget there
are other things that are at play here
so
for the folks saying the impeachment
wouldn't be a strict enough punt it
wouldn't really be much of a punishment
for trump at this point number one
i disagree in that being impeached
and if particularly if he was convicted
or stripped of the ability to run again
would be humiliating for donald trump
and that's a
it's quite a punishment when you
understand donald trump's psyche
there are also other things that would
be significantly deleterious to donald
trump's future but again
it is not about punishment trump's
mishandling of coronavirus
is impeachable uh trump's inciting of
this riot
is impeachable and if he did something
impeachable he must be impeached so
uh i'm i'm tired of the it would be
divisive or it wouldn't be much of a
punishment mindset i'm also by the way
tired of the mindset
that we can just keep him under control
for the next however many days it's not
about that
at this point in time and it's not true
no one has been able to keep him under
control
for any period of time i mean look look
at even last week
he incited the riot then he was
essentially
from what we know forced to go out there
and say
oh uh the violence was bad and there
will be a transition like oh wow he
sounds slightly presidential
it was obviously disingenuous and within
hours he was back on twitter
repeating the same failed the the same
debunked notions
about um uh voter fraud
and 75 million votes and all of this
other stuff so
nobody can control him it's not about
that it's not about punishment it's just
what has to happen and more than half of
the country at this point
believes that donald trump should be
immediately removed